did I send you that little his name is
Little Texas no oh my God can we just
play some right now we can cut out the
music I just want your genuine reaction
to this okay by the way I'm not I'm not
making fun of this guy because I I he
plays like big ass festivals I've seen
he has a really solid fan base people
really like this [__] I think we're I'm
just old okay okay so play uh yeah is it
is the first one Starships yeah play
that and make it loud I got it
you get it
I I think I understand what it what
um I love it because it's like
I like I feel like when we were younger
and Riddim started coming out it was one
thing where you're like whoa like older
people would be like this is robot music
but you're like no this is sick but this
doesn't even have drums it's just
yeah I suggest that like it's crazy
my thought
would be that this generation of people
like they get it
so I think even like get it in terms of
like okay let's like I get it a song has
drums and like get to the part that
makes me feel the good [__] and so I
feel like with not people now
[__] can be so stripped down just to
like the Raw like like when we would
listen to a song
we're [__] old could we sit around we
wait for the chorus yeah the chorus is
like what gives you the good yeah you're
like yeah
and I think this younger generation is
just like they're [__] with the intro
it's just like Vape
you know more media more just pills
[Music]
more
I need the focus
so you're saying if you put music if you
if you were trying to get music in there
it's just like what's the most yeah so
now like I care ear catching yeah you
can do so if you put music in there and
you try some [__] from us where it's
like and in the middle of that it's like
it's hey I just met you it's like this
is crazy they're like no get that um I
feel like they can see it coming they're
like the the chorus like it it's come
just make it right right do the chorus
now but then this how does it how is
this different so I feel like this is
different because it's taking that bit
from starships that makes you feel good
yeah and it's rammed up 500 bpms
so yeah yeah yeah
yes yes that's the part I know yeah and
then they don't want to hear a [__] some
people they don't hear a verse right I
don't even hear you talk about it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah it's the only thing that
like compels them to not look at Tick
Tock yeah you know yeah or like pulls
them away and they're like what is what
is this it's different and I just think
they're doing way more substance it's
like they just need harder [__] to feel
something yeah and I I will say
listening to it in this environment with
you guys on the speakers I get it way
more than when I was alone in my
airplane what the [__] is this no that's
not I was like I don't understand this
at all and it was like one of the first
times that I've sat there and been like
I've totally aged out of something yeah
yeah that's not alone music now play
it's hot in here by Nelly
have you heard the new one
no nle Choppa oh yeah didn't he like
damn near rip the whole song it's pretty
close that's what people were saying
it's pretty close this is like hold
music
to someone who's 20.
I should be thinking about a high
interest savings account yeah you know
what else is hot flashes you are getting
old quickly start saving now
all right now play nle's version now go
back to Little Texas for comparison and
play uh let's pick another one here
what play the fourth one or the fifth
one maybe it's just like he hit so much
yeah
it makes me feel like I'm in an arcade
let's see you got that original on here
[Laughter]
let me tell you about Cialis yeah yeah
exactly side effects of Cialis include
yeah a sick ass boner yeah can we finish
the episode with this yeah you just made
me realize I'm laughing I'm gonna see
Drake tonight no way I'm going on uh
next Monday yeah is he at The Forum
tonight yeah where are you gonna go see
him sick crypto ooh I have the forms way
better yeah Elena Elena's like I've
never been to a concert
we're sitting eating breakfast on Sunday
she's like I've never been to a concert
what
what no a concert ever no
why just wasn't a thing in her family
and just she wasn't brought up in a way
where like live music and [__] was a
that's crazy yeah oh okay so let's let's
not delve into this no no I want to talk
about it oh you do I just want to know
what the [__] drama is why did she
delete the Drake interview
um what could have happened
dude that has to be like the juiciest
piece of piece of [__] drama yeah I
don't like talking about drama but this
I'm like that blew her the [__] up she
went from you know podcast
not like irrelevance but I'm saying like
she had a new podcast it was only like
one episode out from there to like
podcast super stardom in the course of a
[__] week because of that episode and
she took it down why something must have
happened well
yeah they unfollowed each other or
whatever yeah
I wonder what happened
it's kind of crazy or it's a meme yeah
or maybe it's just like did it
just for this
maybe so people are like what's going on
it like draws even more attention could
be yeah I would wager something
happened
a bit of a bit of a Fallout yeah quick
Fallout
unintended consequence yeah are you
excited
uh for the show
I'm not getting my hopes up
why I've seen a lot of rap live
in my life
and rarely ever is it that good yeah
okay that's fair I'll say like
I haven't been to a Show recently so I
know there's like modern artists that
put on like a show like watching Duke
Deuce live is probably insane he does
like wrestling [__] he brings up fans
and he puts them through tables that's
cool I would love to see little Texas
come out there and just tear up
everyone's like what started from the
bottom now we're here yeah play that
song that that's how about this yeah
that's something that's always funny to
me is
when you hear like older people talk
about music
older people now they hear ye it's just
it's too fast yeah you know that's
they're used to
I just [__] some [__]
all right that is borderline clap your
hands everybody You Got What It Takes
that's borderline borderline that's true
you know yeah that's a good point
even if they hear cardi it's like I
really mean they're like it's too fast
yeah yeah I can't always voice is so
squeaky I don't know what he said the
voice is small how is his voice so small
yeah that's a really funny way of
describing yeah his tone thanks dude
well now
I'm laughing because I can't wait
because it you know I can't wait till
gen Z is on that side of it and I wonder
what new [__] is going to come out in
like 10 years that has a gen Z person
like
yeah and what is going to come out in 10
years that makes cardi seem like
a whole lot of red
you know just slow